[music playing]
That was a
wonderful performance.
I wish I could stay.
I think I sang really well.
You always sing well.
But we haven't found
it yet, have we?
Not for lack of trying.
So let's get you
back into the studio,
and put our heads together.
Hammond.
Ted.
Listen, I, uh, I
wish I could linger,
but I have another event.
Congratulations.
Glad you could make it.
On your birthday, last year,
you remember what you wish for?
Have you seen my father?
You said you wanted to
be on the Steve Allen show.
And what did I say to you?
I said, I was going to
make your dreams come true.
And now look at where we are.
He made it all this
way, stayed for the show,
and didn't stay for
the party, which
means he was either
still mad at me,
or, he thought my
performance was bad.
Was it?
No, baby, baby,
baby, no, come on.
Mr. Wexler?
I'm a big fan Aretha.
Ms. Franklin.
Excuse me, Miss Franklin.
You know, I've
launched a few careers.
Atlantic records and me,
we roll up our sleeves,
and we dig deep.
This contract with
Columbia is almost up.
What she does after
that, that's her call.
Columbia's had a good run.
But music's changing.
You got to stay ahead of it, or
you're gonna get left behind.
Can I be honest?
Yeah, please.
Tonight, I wanted to be wowed.
But I wasn't.
I don't think the
audience was, either.
Well, now you're
just plain wrong.
"Skylark" is going
to be classic.
I'm trying everything I can.
You know I work
with Ray Charles?
Genius.
I could do for you,
what I did for Ray.
I could help you
find your sound.
That's what I do.
Now, let me ask you,
what kind of music
do you really want to
make, Miss Franklin?
I want to make
hits, Mr. Wexler.
You'll get there, when
you realize you are Aretha
Franklin, and nobody else.
Pleasure.
Let me freshen your drink.
[music playing]
(SINGING) How I got over.
How I got over.
You know my soul looks back
and wonder how I got over.
How I got over.
You know my soul looks
back and wonder how I over.
Just as soon as I see Jesus,
the man who made me free.
You know, the man, who
bleed and suffered.
You know, he died
for you and me.
I wanna thank you,
because you brought me.
I wanna thank you, Jesus,
because you taught me.
I wanna thank you
because you kept me.
I wanna thank you,
cause you never left me.
I wanna sing.
Oh, [inaudible].
My soul looks back and
wonder how I got over.
How I got over.
You know, my soul looks back
and wonder how I got over.
How I got over, How I got over.
You know, my soul looks back
and wonder how I got over.
[applause]